i wanted to get your thoughts on just
the overall
distrust in media these days oh it's
fake news you can't trust anybody
everything's so polarized you know jeff
zucker resigns roger ale um you know
cuomo just just so much distrust in news
these days as a news man this must be a
little disheartening for you it is and i
think what you've seen is besides
targeting by politicians you know in
this
um catchphrase fake news i mean the
reality is nobody's perfect in the news
business nobody's perfect in politics
nobody's perfect in the financial world
but generally most of the people try to
do the right thing
but with the advent of cable news and
this need or perceived need to take a
point of view
you know fox obviously had a point of
view and it made them successful
their news reporting during the day is
their news reporting but when you get to
personalities and point of view at night
the same with msnbc or the same at cnn
it creates polarization
and it creates targeting
and i think when you elevate that for
ratings you take the risk
of being painted on one side or the
other
and we've lost what happens at 6 30 for
the evening news and we lost what
happens between
10 in the morning and and 5 at night on
cable news which is generally speaking
reporting i mean you you watch on fox
you see their correspondent in ukraine
showing this incredible story all day
long and then you get to some of the
columnist opinionator opinionated people
and they're telling a whole different
story and
saying what's wrong with putin and
everything else when all day long
their guys have been dodging mortar
shells in the field yeah you know
telling the real story do you think
there should be a disclaimer like
opinion journalism
actual news the viewer needs to be aware
of what you're looking at but there's
such a gray line it is it is and that's
like you're watching this you're
watching the four o'clock news
uh with brett bear and then next on the
five is a bunch of opinions right so you
got to switch your mind over that was
the news now it's opinions same thing on
cnn it goes from wolf blitzer to boom
now it's don lemon and now you're
so
do you think the media needs to be held
accountable to say
this is the news portion facts this is
the opinion portion take it with a grain
of salt i think i think that they need
to us
the best consumer is an educated
consumer and so i think you know there
is a certain responsibility that we have
but also i think the you know the people
watching
need to know
and be aware that look this has just
crossed from over over from reporting
and journalism to somebody's opinion but
you're putting that on the people just
well i think a consumer
news i think people i think people know
it i i do this
maybe they should maybe i'm not saying
i'm not saying you're wrong by the way
i'm just saying that you know are we
insulting to the viewer by saying okay
we're leaving the news portion of the
day and here's this personality doing it
i mean i think people sort of know that
maybe you're right
i'm not arguing it i'm just saying that
you know when when i
answer these questions when i look at
these situations i try to give the
viewer who was generally incredibly
intelligent
you know credit for being are you giving
the viewer too much credit chris
i don't think so
i mean maybe some
but i mean i i think i think
what does denzel say denzel says if you
watch the news
you're misinformed if you don't watch
the news you're uninformed you've got to
pick one of the two right if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you